nascar weekend continues to rev up over
at the las vegas motor speedway
with the return of the pennzoil 400
kevin martin joins us live from the
track with more on how fans are enjoying
the action
kevin good evening orgo for the third
straight day nascar fans were out and
about at the las vegas motor speedway as
people were permitted
back inside in a limited capacity for
the first time
in nearly a year in all three races this
weekend friday's truck race yesterday's
xfinity race in today's cup race
were sell outs with roughly 12 500
people
in attendance and all of those people
are expected to follow strict
health and safety protocols including
the mandatory use of face coverings
health screening
social distancing frequent hand
sanitization and protocols ranging from
digital tickets to cashless purchases
a safe way for fans to enjoy a weekend
out at the track
just being back at the raceway feels
good because like i came here
every year except last year because the
covet you know but
it feels good to be back mingling
amongst people
you know everybody's here for the same
reason so
it's a good time it's a good time
everybody's here for you know have fun
glad to be just here and able to
just watch a race and be out and be out
with the family and
it's awesome man
and fans were treated to a show on the
track kyle larson taking the checkered
flag in the pennzoil 400 his first
win since being reinstated by nascar
after last season's
indefinite suspension he beat out brad
keselowski who finished second
in las vegas native kyle busch taking
third reporting live at the las vegas
motor speedway
kevin martin 8 sports now